i want to show you this as well
i i don't know if you're ready to meet
this person this is the most pathetic
man potentially in the history of the
internet and i know that's quite a
statement but i think he's in the
running anyway he's he's in the
competition this is a guy walking
through an airport we have these uh
pictures
um
oh here we go so this guy's name is
aiden
and by the way of course he has his
pronouns listed in his bio i don't have
to tell you that
and you can't really see his picture
there very well but he looks exactly as
you expect him to look
and he says spotted in the united
terminal at san francisco airport i've
been in four airports this week and far
from travelers far more travelers flaunt
the mask regulations in u.s airports
versus the canadian ones
i hope i'm not sitting next to her on
this red eye and then you see a woman
who's just like sitting on the phone
uh without a mask on
and so he's taking a picture of this
woman to publicly shame her and by the
way posted this to twitter
this is against the rules now this is
supposed to be against the rules they
take up they they very they're very
explicit about this to take a picture of
someone and post it without their
consent is against the rules that gets
you banned
but he's walking through the whole
airport and taking pictures of him then
he gets another guy man watching
something on his tablet at uh gate e4
so there's just a guy
watching something on his tablet and
he's taking a picture of this guy no
consent and he gets
there's another guy he takes a picture
of him
i think there's one in the airplane as
well so he's just walking through
man with stylish backpack between gates
e4 and f5 so he's given the exact exact
coordinates of these masculist people at
the airport i don't know for what reason
does he think the fbi is going to swoop
in i'm not sure what exactly he's trying
to accomplish
um
and then he's got man super spreader
gate f5
that guy is a super spreader aiden has
decided of course his name is aiden by
the way everything about this when i
first saw that i think this is i thought
that's got to be some kind of parody
there's no way this is too perfect
a guy named aiden with a mustache and
pronouns in his bio
walking through the airport crying as he
takes pictures of massless people
um
but it's not a parody this appears to be
completely real
and he's just determined that he's also
decided by the way that all of these
people are sick
and he goes on and on how many pictures
are there he's now he's taking pictures
of minors of kids
posting them online without consent this
is perfectly okay twitter's not going to
take this down
all right so we get the idea
um
he's decided that all these people are
sick
this is the way that his his his broken
brain
works now or does or fails to work
that every single person he sees
if he sees their face in public
they are direct threat to him
and they're all sick
and they're all super spreaders i mean
that one guy was sitting by himself
there's no one else around
and but he's he's now a super spreader
this is
along with a mental illness this is
also pure cowardice you know c.s lewis
said that
that courage is the form of every virtue
at its testing point
and uh which means that you know you
can't
you can't really have
any other virtue if you don't have
courage
because in order to in order to
act upon any virtue
in order to be virtuous then you that
also requires
courage
to act in that way
so then what does it mean when we become
a country of cowards
when we become a country like this with
with me i i hesitate to even call him a
man only in a bi only in the biological
sense is he a man
but what does that mean
and if we become a country of cowards it
means that we have no virtue at all you
get rid of uh courage you get rid of all
virtues
and these are people who
are not only cowardly but they have no
shame and there have always been cowards
in the world right
but in the past you'd be ashamed of your
cowardice you wouldn't want to advertise
it
if you found yourself walking through
a public area
uh shaking like a leaf in fear
because you're afraid someone's gonna
get you sick
in the past you might have that
experience if you're a very cowardly
person but you keep it to yourself you
wouldn't want other people to know
now you've got people like aiden
advertising their cowardice for for
everyone to see
they're proud of it they're proud of
being fearful cowards
that has become its own in our
upside-down world that has become its
own virtue
now it's almost as though cowardice is
the is the form of every virtue at its
testing point
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated